du coup sa meilleure aujourd'hui c'est
une société une agence digitale
nous vous accompagnons toutes les
entreprises et même les particuliers
aussi dans leur parcours numérique on a
plusieurs parlent de nos services qu'on
propose aux entreprises et des packs de
création d'identités visuelles jusqu'à
la conception du site internet ou même
de l'application mobile
[Musique]
j'ai un parcours assez atypique parce
que j'ai fait une formation stlg géant
braqué ce thème jours ça a été sujet et
après je voulais continuer les études
mais chercher notamment si j'ai pas
trouvé d'alternance du coup je me suis
dirigé vers une formation développeurs
web chez hitchcock et après ça je me
suis dit vu que les alternances est
compliqué à avoir parce qu'il faut de
l'expérience on va se réapproprie ans de
cela
[Applaudissements]
j'ai lancé officieusement en janvier
2020 est officiellement le taux d'erreur
parce que la paperasse projet trans je
ne suis pas approché par ce qu un mois
des professionnels c'est plutôt quand le
projet a été monté qu'il cherchait des
professionnels pour être des partenaires
pendant pendant cette démarche et cette
aventure pour la formation de société
pour l'argent je suis approché de clowns
bloquent tout est parti des fonds
personnels